[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video i've got something a
little bit different for you guys
i've covered book drafts and unpublished
content in the past
but i don't think i've ever covered
anything quite like this
today i'm going to be introducing you
all to an alternate
deleted unpublished scene from the
chamber of secrets
where instead of crashing into the
whomping willow harry and ron instead
crash into the lake outside of hogwarts
now as we know this particular outcome
never occurred
harry and ron crashed into the whomping
willow and that's that
but in this scenario harry and ron find
themselves submerging
the lake it's at this point that they're
saved by none other than
mer people newt scamander author of
fantastic beasts and where to find them
describes merpeople as the following in
his book
the oldest recorded mer people were
known as sirens
greece and it is in warmer waters that
we find the beautiful mermaids more
frequently depicted
in muggle literature and painting the
selkies of scotland and the marrows of
ireland
are less beautiful but they share that
love of music which is common to all mer
people
essentially mer people are sentient
magical beasts that live under water
and as noted above they can be found all
over the world
they are certainly mysterious creatures
that we don't get to know very well in
the story
only playing a relatively small role
outside of hogwarts they reside in the
black lake
and we really only see them during the
events of the second task
of the triwizard tournament where they
agree to keep four people
in an enchanted sleep in their village
for an hour
protecting them until they are saved by
their respective champion
they're certainly odd creatures and
though they were offered at the status
of a being in the magical world
they refused in favor of beast mainly
because they did not wish to share a
status
with hags and vampires with all that
said
in this scene that i'm about to
introduce you to the mer people can be
seen saving harry and ron
from the slowly submerging ford anglia
they are able to flip the car over
and drag it back to shore where harry
and ron get out
this was the first time that harry ever
saw mer people
a momentous occasion if we look at the
top of page 64
it's very clear that an editor for the
book has made notes
remarking that the chapter in question
may need a rewrite
this is probably the reason we never
ended up getting this scene
but it's certainly interesting to look
at so let's dive into it
no pun intended page 62
harry thought happily of ice cold drinks
in the best gold goblets
and platters piled high with delicious
hogwarts food
they flew over the edge of the great
lake now the castle right ahead of them
why are you slowing down said harry i'm
not said ron
stamping on the accelerator i don't
understand
the car was definitely slowing now they
were going at a walking pace
what's wrong with it said ron frowning
at the dashboard
why isn't it ron said harry suddenly
pointing at a dial beside the steering
wheel
we're out of petrol what's petrol said
ron
it's what you need to make a car go said
harry irritably
well why didn't you say so before said
ron as the car began to shudder
alarmingly
i didn't know a bewitched car would need
it said harry grabbing the edges of his
seat as the car began to vibrate
madly on the spot oh no said ron weakly
his knuckles white on the steering wheel
if the engine cuts out
the words were barely out of his mouth
when the engine spluttered and died
no ron yelled the car dropped like a
boulder they hit the glassy
surface of the lake with a deafening
smash harry was thrown against a window
hedwig was screaming again ron's foot
hit harry in the mouth
icy water was pouring in from somewhere
and the car sank
slowly and steadily through the
blackness scabbers ran across harry's
face
water was sloshing about inside harry
seemed to be sitting on the ceiling of
the car
harry kimron's voice again through the
dark what
how come we're not dead page 63
the windows have shut themselves dad
must have added safety spells
are you hurt something's bleeding but i
think i'm okay
are you all right harry felt the back of
his head i've got a lump like an egg but
nothing feels broken
how are we going to get out of this
dunno there was a jolt
and an ominous silence the roof of the
car had hit the bottom of the lake
well we can still breathe said ron but i
don't know how long that's going to last
will anyone know we're here i don't know
you can't see the lake from the train
station
can you maybe someone from hogwarts was
looking out of the window
yeah maybe said ron bravely the
headlights were still working
they could see a few feet of murky water
and black rocks on the floor of the lake
neither of them spoke for a while we'll
have to thank your dad if we
when we get out said harry eventually
tell him his safety spells worked
yeah harry ron's voice was trembling
did you see something move out there
harry stared out at the water
illuminated by the headlights there was
nothing there but a few specks of sand
were swirling
as though it had been disturbed what did
you think you saw
harry asked it was hard to keep your
voice calm and unconcerned when your
mouth was so dry
it looked like an enormous fishtail
whispered wrong
page 64. oh well a fish said harry
a fish isn't going to do anything to us
i thought it might be the giant squid
there was a pause in which harry wished
he hadn't thought about the giant squid
there's loads of them said ron swiftly
round and gazing out of the rear window
harry felt as though tiny spiders were
crawling up his spine
large dark shadows were circling the car
if it's just
fish he repeated and then into the light
swam something harry had never expected
to see as long as he lived
it was a woman a cloud of blackest hair
thick and tangled like seaweed
floated all around her her lower body
was a great
scaly fishtail the colour of gunmetal
ropes of shells and pebbles hung about
her neck
her skin was a pale silvery grey and her
eyes
flashing in the headlights looked dark
and threatening
she gave a powerful flick of her tail
and sped into the darkness
was that a mermaid said harry well it
wasn't the giant squid
said ron there was a crunching noise and
the car suddenly shifted
harry scrambled about to press his face
against the back window
about 10 mer people bearded men as well
as long-haired women
were straining against the car their
tails swishing behind them
where they going to take us said ron
panicking
the mermaid they had seen first wrapped
on a window next to harry
made a circular motion with her silvery
hand i think they're going to flip us
over
said harry quickly hold on page 65
they grabbed the door hands and slowly
as the merpeople pushed and strained
the car turned right over onto its
wheels clouds of silt fogging the water
hedwig was beating her wings furiously
against the bars of her cage again
the mer people were now binding thick
slimy ropes of lakeweed around the car
and tying the ends around their own
waists then
with harry and ron sitting in the front
seats hardly daring to breathe
they pulled the car was lifted off the
bottom and rose toward the mer people
to the surface yes said ron as they saw
the starry sky again through their
drenched windows
the mer people in front looked like
seals their sleek heads
just visible as they towed the car
towards the bank
a few feet from the grassy bank they
felt the wheels touched the pebbly
ground of the lake again
the merpeople sank out of sight then the
first mermaid bobbed up harry's window
and wrapped on it he unwound it quickly
we can take you no further
she said she had a strange voice it was
both screechy and hoarse
the rocks are sharp in the shallows but
legs are not so easily torn
as fins no said harry nervously
look we can't thank you enough the
mermaid gave a little flick of her tail
and was gone
come on i need food said ron who was
shivering
they opened the doors of the car with
difficulty picked up hedwig and scabbers
braced themselves and jumped down into
the freezing water
which came up above harry's thighs they
waded to the bank and climbed out
not as pretty as they look in books are
they mermaids
said ron trying to bring out his jeans
of course they were lake people
maybe in a warm sea harry didn't answer
he was having trouble with hedwig who
had clearly had enough of wizard
transport he let her out of her cage and
she sawed off at once
towards a high tower which housed all
the school owls
this is the end of the chapter but i do
want to also mention the note from the
editor on page
64. i wondered whether the merpeople
scene
actually works after all we don't see
them again
what if as an alternative the car
suddenly develops underwater boosters or
something
and suddenly shoots out of the water
might help pace too
what you just witnessed was a piece of
harry potter history
an unpublished draft that heavily
deviates from the existing story
of one of the most popular books ever
what do you guys think of it
would you have left it in did you prefer
the incident with a whomping willow
had you heard of this before comment
down below
until next time the truth it is a
beautiful and a terrible thing
and should therefore be treated with
[Music]
caution
you